here are the latest calls between former
President Obama and President Trump
hello you see my speech
yeah over and right parts of it we're
good a great but you've worried I get
them all
well congrats I get I get all the right
words just like my word guys wrote them
yeah even the big words
I did all the words good bad all the
words were over there on that screen but
then they came out of my bath there it
would intersect yeah that's called
reading a teleprompter calabaza
teleprompter depo copter hello aber egg
I just got back from another incredible
rally
isn't it a little premature campaign for
re-election people are already talking
about impeachment yeah but if they get
in peace think of all the time I'll have
to get paying for 2020 that's not how it
works you have no idea how many times a
day I hear this I figured it out you
figured what out how to turn this thing
around all I need is a catchphrase like
you buy it I think it's gonna take more
than a catchphrase
so listen tell me what you like that
you're the board is no cube a powerful
George reveals confusing you know
terrified you're transgender
no idea what that is you can add the
dream to be sooner or later you're my
way
there I'm not going to the White House
Correspondents Dinner yeah I heard
what's the matter you can't take a joke
I just take a joke little Tommy's got
thin skin
stop calling me little Johnny just get
Donnie come on I'm just kidding
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you